rich why do you think women are going to
be single and childless within the next
nine years top shelf men are starting to
avoid insufferable women there's not a
lot of incentive anymore to have in
families
and children that leaves a lot of you
know women out to climb the corporate
ladder
collect cats and box wine subscriptions
and um go globalism feminism and all the
other isms
only 2.9 of women are really interested
in your average guy and that's going to
have a horrific effect
on the future economic production of the
united states or let alone any other
country with very low birth rates
when women are making more money than
men on an evolutionary level it's hard
for women to accept that
even if a couple starts out making
exactly the same amount of money if that
woman gets a a bonus but she gets a
raise or she gets a promotion of some
sort
that is a precipitator of a divorce if
guys
just go out and do what rich talks about
if you just pursue
excellence and you do not pursue women
you're going to have the best of both
worlds because women they can say
whatever but if they want a guy that can
really take
charge